[Música]
[Aplausos]
bom judiação dessa equipe viu me colocar
nesse bloco
depois de tombar danço toquem não tá né
quero montar e aí mas já tem começa a
batida do coração não foi à toa é um
caminho que eu encontrei pra conectar o
meu coração ao coração de vocês possa
segurar e lesou nem precisava dizer acho
que vocês podem concluir que não é um
coração no estado qualquer está com
tanta emoção que está até difícil falar
com vocês nós vamos começar
bom eu quis conectar o meu coração o
coração de vocês pra falar de um
propósito um propósito que já não
acompanha alguns anos mais
especificamente uma mudança de paradigma
mas pra que vocês entendam melhor esse
propósito preciso contar uma história a
história de um menino o menino nasceu de
parto normal através da sua mãe até que
ela parteira e benzedeira numa condição
socioeconômica ou nada favorável
só que ela era obstinado a idealizadora
tinha anser de crescimento com uma
maioria de vocês eu acredito a ela
encarava os desafios gostava de encarar
os desafios e questiona aquilo que
estava pré estabelecido e buscar a
solução ou seja
dá palpite bom com esse perfil foi
natural que ela desce um outro passo
assim que ela cresceu porque apesar de
nunca terem ido ao médico a favor dela
era benzedeiro então era cuidada com
reza nunca ter nasceu avó que era para
tentar nem conhecia médico nenhum né e
como falei também uma condição de muita
adversidade pela situação socioeconômica
mas mesmo assim ela resolveu enfrentar o
vestibular mais difícil da época e foi
justamente de 1.800 então quando ela
chegou na faculdade de medicina de a
menor noção do que era um contexto
médico hospitalar e uma coisa chamou a
atenção dela logo de cara foi logo mesmo
faculdade ela percebeu o seguinte se o
exercício da medicina exige um elevado
grau de humanização
então porque no processo de ensino cie
priorizavam a técnica que a ciência nem
se dava confiança para o estudante a
pessoa do aluno o desenvolvimento do
aluno ficava em segundo plano
isso aconteceu já tem muito tempo gente
acessórios femininos
só que pelo jeito não mudou muita coisa
nova quando quando ela foi prato ela viu
também uma outra coisa meio
descompassado que é o fato de que apesar
de seu do sistema ser chamado sistema de
saúde ele era centrado na doença sinal
na saúde o paciente geral não era visto
era vista doença do paciente e não do és
bom
a questão então era que a visão era
reducionista e não privilegiavam não
colocava em destaque o investimento
humano é esse era o paradigma era ao
pegar ou largar então não tinha
não tinha muita escolha então é lógico
que a primeira sensação que veio após
investir tanto e acabei fazendo uma
escolha errada mas com núbia é um
problema a resolver
mas como ela era uma pessoa que tinha
uma natureza artística habilidosa
gostava de aço já se envolvia com com
esse processo ela aparentemente achou
uma saída quando convidaram ela pra
assistir a uma cirurgia plástica
naturalmente condenou o procedimento ela
decidiu que aquela seria especial dada
parecia que estava tudo muito bem
resolvido só que durante os longos anos
de exercício da especialidade
ela se deu conta também de outro
outro paradoxo um descompasso entre a
estética humana que parte de um ser vivo
que pensa sente e se modifica nebbia
adolescente jovem envelhece tal e uma
outra estética que era padronizada
focada só na aparência física em geral
meio que referende múltiplos interesse
muitos deles dizem ter interesse
inclusive desumano ou seja na busca
desenfreada por procedimentos tangíveis
e com resultado rápido como a lipo nem
lipospiração por exemplo ou botões as
pessoas pouco investiu no que ela
chamava de estética do ser que dependia
é dada junção entre corpo mente e
espírito do equilíbrio entre entre esses
três elementos sem o qual é a gente não
consegue sustentar os pilares da
autoestima e da autoconfiança é óbvio
que assim que tudo toda tinha que sair
por alguma via e na ocasião que ela
encontrou como saída foi abrir uma
clínica na época inovadora e muito bem
sucedida em que além dos procedimentos
estéticos ela viajava também é ações
direcionados para a saúde e para a
conscientização
nesse ato ela abriu a possibilidade da
construção de um segundo eixo
também o oposto do outro é um eixo que
iria priorizar o desenvolvimento humano
priorizar o investimento humano desse
eixo nasceu uma estratégia pedagógica
que usava a experiência do dia a dia no
caso das benesses do próprio passar dos
próprios pacientes como referências para
eles desenvolverem autoconhecimento
autoestima tal enfim tudo isso que faz
parte do mano só quando ela estava no
auge desse empreendimento ela foi
surpreendida por uma doença neurológica
que foi difícil de ser é acertado
diagnóstico e isso comprometeu
drasticamente seus movimentos e enfim dá
piorando porque foi um início abrupto
depois ela tinha surtos a cada surto
piorava no processo de piora jogo na
hora que não dava mais pra continuar as
atividades teve que desativar a sua
clínica ou seja estava pra quem é de
volta redonda sabe tava no comper no
portal da saudade que é o cemitério
principal aí então mantinha uma coisa
também muito curiosa ao mesmo tempo que
ela vivenciava todas a limitação física
sap hora ela percebeu um aumento nada do
aspecto intelectual afetivo a visão de
mundo enfim é o sentimento era muito
positiva pesado de dados o desastre
físico apesar daquela é sensação de
tinto finitude
mas exatamente por ter nesse estado ela
se deu conta que não dava mais para
ficar fazendo um rascunho
a gente não faz com que na vida a gente
vai fazer uma vez às vezes quando se
tratava da beirada tipo ou você faz a
coisa direito que não vai dar tempo de
fazer de novo então as pergunto o que
digo que de fato valeria a pena investir
até no tempo restava da vida dela foi e
aí
coerente com trajeto que ela fazia
resposta foi bem incisiva
é na estética do ser a estética humano
a partir dessa resposta que ela se deu a
flor bom fixou o olhar lá no segundo
eixo aquele que permitiria desenvolver
pessoas abrir um site para favorecer sua
conexão com o mundo nesse site colocou
um blog uma galeria jazz que era
apaixonada por assis um modo geral e o
próprio o programa tal programa que eu
falei que era estratégia pedagógica
lepra desenvolvimento pessoas que tinha
o nome delas conversa ela colocou esse
programa no site e passou a aplicar à
distância através de encontros online
tá bom então a partir dessa experiência
nem preciso dizer o quanto que ela
ampliou o ângulo de visão dela o ângulo
de percepção de mudança notável com
muita clareza o seguinte que o mundo era
submetido a um permanente paradoxo
porque ao mesmo tempo em que prática
quase tudo o que nele ocorria fosse
decorrente das ações humanas poucos
investir na qualificação humana na
qualidade desenvolvimento humano né
então para rompê e isso obviamente
trazia sérias conseqüências para romper
esse paradigma
o melhor para romper com esse paradoxo
era preciso investir mais no sujeito da
ação do que na ação do sujeito ou seja e
verteu paradigma
essa menina habita dentro de mim
ela me desperta todos os dias e como
farol e lume no meu caminho para que eu
não me perca essa menina sou eu
bom
a partir dessa dessa vivência é bom aí
tem essa essa amiga que me acompanha
bengala foi meu pai fins nem da
artesanal foi feito com um galho de uma
árvore e ela traz também uma simbologia
porque ao mesmo tempo que ela me ajuda a
quem tá aí vendo o dia inteiro ver o
quanto ela me ajuda a equilibrar nos pas
ao mesmo tempo real a me lembro o quanto
eu sou humana eo quanto eu preciso de
apoio e na sua empreitada que não me
lancei na no sentido de colocar toda a
minha atenção toda a energia que eu
tenho é com o propósito único de
contribuir pra pra que de fato a gente
consiga resgatar essa humanidade que
está dentro da gente quem trinca que a
gente vai perdendo com o tempo é
evidente que para dar conta dessa
empreitada é ninguém faz isso sozinho
precisa estar conectado com outras
pessoas
então quando eu vejo eventos como esse
que fazer quando me convidaram para vir
aqui
primeiro nem tinha idéia de que era uma
coisa tão do tamanho que é eu te
confesso que quando eu confesso a vocês
que quando eu me dei conta o cabo do
tamanho a favor ele porque é o meu
estilo é olho no olho que me conhece
sabe disso né de grupos pequenos não
estou acostumada com tanta gente
enfim mas eu achava achei agora estou
mais do que convencida que vale a pena
eu aceitar porque aqui eu encontrarei
meus pares e é isso que eu acho que está
acontecendo eu toco tentou encontrar
meus base então é o que quando eu vi lá
o nep peter de x volta redonda é o
subtítulo a sociedade além do aço né
ah eu fiquei pensando nela pensando em
volta redonda que a cidade que eu moro
onde eu tô tanto tempo fala
além do aço pulsão corações que clamam
por humanidade não só lá eu acho que o
mundo inteiro país clama por isso né eu
época quer dizer uma das alegrias que eu
tive quando eu recebi o convite porque
ele veio através disso veio desse
trabalho né me deu muita alegria porque
quando você tem uma idéia alguma coisa
que te apaixona muito que te envolve que
você percebe
às vezes se tem idéia de só você que tá
vendo aquilo né e às vezes acontece
mesmo como diz o colega que antecedeu
aqui é evidente que eu também tenho meu
lado de loucura não fugir à regra então
às vezes a gente enxerga uma coisa
achando que ela tá enfim está no momento
certo da gente colocar e às vezes não tá
então é quando eles vieram me convidar
eu tive também a noção disso quer dizer
então isso que eu estou percebendo como
necessário e que eu tô vendo que a fala
das pessoas que vieram antes de mim que
tudo barra a mesma coisa quer dizer se
você tem uma pessoa se é uma pessoa que
é de fato humanizado sensível outro que
tem um empate e respeita o outro
você não precisa de lei são precisas de
rega naturalmente ela vai fazer isso
então não adianta você dizer pra você
vai fazer ou não vai fazer você vai
pagar tanto de multa
se você paga não fizer vai preso e aí a
gente vê que está faltando cada vez mais
presentes e presídios porque não adianta
você investir na ação é negativa da
pessoa senão você se você não investe no
desenvolvimento dela como pessoa a quem
investe uma criança mas com estratégias
que a gente usa para investir no adulto
o adulto já foi uma criança e por uma
questão de modelo de comportamento do
que a gente vê acontecendo no no
cotidiano esse adulto e se esse adulto
que foi criança ele se deteriorada então
o que fazer
quer dizer só só aconselhar ou dizer
para a pessoa fazer
eles vão tentar tanese está dizendo eu
tava então fazer o que é claro que não
tem resposta pronta eu tenho eu tenho eu
tenho uma estratégia aqui evidentemente
é tem dado certo em funcionar mas eu
acredito que na verdade seja a soma de
estratégias aqui né a karina a enfim dá
todas as pessoas que passaram por aqui
que já estão desenvolvendo um trabalho
super bacana
talvez esteja falando aí o tédio sugere
isso né porque o ted atrai pessoas que
têm esse perfil e ao mesmo tempo como se
estivesse dizendo eu tô aqui facilitando
a ampliação da rede né eu tô aqui amplie
é propondo sugerindo a união de forças
eu tô aqui propondo continuidade
então eu acho que esse estímulo né que o
tek tanan eu eu vejo como uma
possibilidade sim da gente somar forças
na e cada um trocando com outra
experiência que ele o que ele tem vivido
e tem dado certo a gente inteligente
mesmo que eu falo que é o
desenvolvimento humano não é uma questão
amorosa
nem é uma questão é romântica o ou né
ligado a ele joeli religiosidade ou
coisa do tipo
a questão do desenvolvimento humano é
ligado à inteligência não é inteligente
intelligent a gente não investir na
gente como seres humanos não é
inteligente então a pessoa pode não
valer nada entendeu tipo cara temos ser
lá essas coisas mas ela foi inteligência
obviamente montou contabilizando é que
os psicopatas não é porque pra eles até
então deve contabilizar então tirando
esse time todo o resto com certeza se
for inteligente não agi mal porque não é
um bom negócio
irmão então nem tem mais muita coisa pra
dizer pra vocês né eu poderia finalizar
acho até que eu gostaria de finalizar
com até breve porque a minha esperança é
que a gente continue conectado
eu falei que precisava conectar meu
coração o coração de vocês espero que
vocês não temos deixado na mão né tá
então estou confiando que o coração da
gente está conectado e que a gente vai
estar agora no processo de até breve
mesmo não é adeus o som obrigada a boca
[Aplausos]